I'll turn on boom like just to get
motivated to magnetar I'm like you know
country like the hit country radio
station I'm like this is [ __ ] hip-hop
this is rednecks rapping over hip-hop
beats like I'd rather than NWA I'm not
going to some [ __ ] this [ __ ]
shitty country ranch right now your
music taste is very broad you love
everything I love everybody I yeah I
mean I grew up probably on it to be
honest because I was rebelling against
worse from I grew up on probably more
rock probably she listened to Sabbath
and all that [ __ ] you know Zeppelin
everything and then I got into like I
said when you kind of go out see no no
it's trying to play you wailing you'll
be like no no that's my music you take
you take authorship of it later but who
were your early influences well me and
the guy produced my records whose
amazing by the way we had the same we
had both agreed much my friends agreed
it all starts with the Beatles for us on
TV Doug the Beatles but like literally
the first time I I heard about the first
Buck Owens song I heard was Ringo
singing act naturally the cool thing
about the Beatles was you could you
could listen to it and hear every time
you could hear Chuck Berry you could
hear rest in peace you could hear helter
skelter was basically metal you could
hear like almost opera kind of and
you're having classical music a little
bit and like you know Eleanor Rigby or
you could hear country like I said they
would play a lot of countries almost
like a they did like Carl Park and [ __ ]
you mean that you could use you hear
every type of music did you like the
whole discography of the Eagle of the
Beatles yeah I like you know yeah other
thoroughly [ __ ] drives me crazy
I'm like yeah I don't know at 66 on with
that album and all that music on offer
and whiteout episode and Rubber Soul and
the one would know they were to India
they went to India let it be said Noah
with the [ __ ] ha was the thing when
Sergeant Pepper
I like sergeant pepper's a magical
mystery tour how I can
on the borderline of help how much you
helped help I like that no I can't help
but ask the help I like everything
it whether it be is brilliant I will say
that I'm with you I don't find myself
listening to early Beatles now you know
no no no they're like it sounds like
kind of bells teenybopper means but you
know what I [ __ ] listen to music a
lot and you broadened me tonight when
you said that the Beatles covered
everything because I got to tell you son
as soon as you said that I heard the
chords - she loves you yeah in the
beginning of it and I was like oh [ __ ]
he's right I've heard that before I have
heard that before maybe somebody took it
from them well not the same chord the
same done an N and not that stuff but
just that twang in the court that
Jonathan had or George Harrison was the
real catalyst there with the guitar but
people have know the Beatles anymore
The Beatles don't even [ __ ] matter
people have you know P kids are growing
up and here three Beatles songs on the
radio
and they don't understand what to be
those men I feel like when I was a kid I
love you guys tell me but I feel about I
was a kid maybe that time it was like
the Beatles were kind of cool but Elvis
was like oldies music and I feel like
fields not turning into oldies but the
problem with the Beatles is that unless
you grew up with a generation and your
parents like the Beatles what happen if
you're lost in wheels all you know about
the Beatles is the radio the songs on
the radio you really never put the whole
you'd ever put on rubber sole or [ __ ]
once what's not tomorrow tomorrow never
know god that's the best [ __ ] sound
that's from that's from a revolver
revolver yeah
then have a listen to revolvers they
don't understand the hold the changes
those [ __ ] been made you know
how our band can't stay together than
three albums how many how many these
savages have just expertly give me you
know someone told someone told me that
from the time they started to when they
broke up
they put out the the whole career lasted
the same amount that you two takes
between records so someone told me got
you to the band you too you know on
average they said they take like six
seven years to make a new record that's
how long the whole Beatle score here was
stuck in the end
yeah their plane landed in um in New
York is when when people first heard of
them was 63 they broke up in 70 the
whole career was seven years and happily
Adams they put a eston I mean pride ten
I mean prop maybe more but well it's
weird because they had demo I'm out for
an amount and that albums were different
in England and here's some of them so
it's hard to say it the exact amount
they just said twelve if you if you
didn't listen to The Beatles what would
you recommend somebody to start with
what out well it wouldn't matter no
matter who the person was I would say I
think we just came across revolver as a
good woman kind of got a little bit of
everything
I would actually you know what Ozzy's
favorite album of all time is is what
the White Album
the one our mood brew is why all this
great Kisuke again as an example you get
everything
I mean helter skelter is more metal than
most [ __ ] you or more hard rock the most
you'll hear nowadays then you got little
ballads and weird [ __ ] Ringo [ __ ] all
over the place no no it's it nobody
really listens when I was growing up
people were really into the Beatles and
then when John Lennon died like a whole
[ __ ] era people went away because
that's what they were holding Hunter
that's what they were hopefully onto is
the Beatle get back together seriously I
wish I was 17
Savan he got young and I still remember
going to New York that Sunday and at the
time I was the big oak eyebrows at the
time I did not one was the Beatles of
Springsteen I was not interested I was a
Zeppelin Sabbath Pat Benatar anti-b were
against the I was I was against the
Beatles because so many people like the
Beatles it drove me [ __ ] bananas and
then years later income
Rhino was I got 66 through whatever like
wait a second these [ __ ] wanted
to Sunday and then I want the one you
mentioned Tomorrow Never Knows that's my
all-time favorite [ __ ] feeling it's
brilliant if you're on acid that's all
they brought the acid to you that was
the first time you ever tripped the
first time you know I think I know you
have to check me I think that was the
first time John one and so acid maybe
well they went to India something I
don't know I'm not a big storm now
because I I don't think feel destroyed
am i heard a beer at a party in LA or
something they took acid for the first
time and uh oh he does a song she said
you know that one Jeff she said I know I
know what it's like to be dead is a
Henry Fonda they were all NASA to some
party Henry Fonda walked up to John
Lennon goes I know what it's like to be
dead gentleman just took it but in that
some yeah that's the old [ __ ] party
days yeah not a lot of people even I
would yeah I would listen to revolve the
White Album I definitely get let it be
yeah ain't no way that let it be thought
of as there were some I think it's one
of us no I like it I like the frame you
know I haven't had the physical beer
arms which now I'm going to start going
buying physical bead arms
next time I go to Burbank come on the
Bison physical Beatle arms it's time
you're absolutely right